[MUSIC]
My name is Dan Miller.
I am the founder and
CEO of Spora Health.
We are a primary care practice
uniquely designed for
people of color.
I've had hundreds of meetings from
Fortune 100 companies down to
startups.
I'm often the only person of color
in the room trying to get folks to
understand the experience of black
and brown people and
how they relate to healthcare and
the issues that are impacting them.
It's increasingly important for
more representation not just in
senior leadership across tech and
business but
especially in healthcare.
If we don't meet those expectations
then people don't get access.
Those things motivate me to create
more impacts professionally to help
more folks to think thoughtfully
about what representation
really means and why it matters.
As an entrepreneur,
I don't have much time.
I needed to find a way for me
to upskill myself but also learn in
an incredible environment to make
sure that I am building the best
business and the best culture.
I was very confident in my skills
to go from zero to one but going
from one to N was very new for me.
There are incredible professors
here and other classmates that have
thought about these problems and
challenges in depth.
And there's a lot of research and
support that SEP and Stanford can
offer entrepreneurs to help them
progress throughout their careers.
It's been an incredible experience
to learn from folks that
have thought a lot about not just
growing business, not just creating
innovative environments but
also leaving a positive impact.
With this focus on making the world
a more positive place and
more equitable place.
[MUSIC]